There's nothing like getting up to preach and like half of the people just
turning around and leaving every single week. We've come to the end of our
series on the book of Ephesians. This is our very first series together at
Trinity Fellowship. As we've begun it's been wonderful to walk through this
together and just to give you a heads up next week we're going to start a new
series which is going to be on the Gospel of John. We're not going to
be walking through the whole book of John like we've been doing with
Ephesians. Instead we're going to be looking at the I am statements of Jesus
throughout the book looking at who Jesus is and what he did. But so as we come to
this final section in Ephesians please do turn with me in your Bibles to Ephesians
6 and Dan is going to be reading that for us. Thank you Dan. Finally be strong in
the Lord and in the strength of his might put on the whole armor of God
that you may be able to stand against the schemes of the devil. Praying at
all times in the spirit and with all prayer and supplication to that end keep
alert with all perseverance making supplication for all the saints and also
for me the words may be given to me in opening my mouth boldly to proclaim the
mystery of the gospel for which I am an ambassador in chains that I may
declare it boldly as odd to speak so that you also may know how I am and
what I am doing. Taikakus the beloved brother and faithful minister in the
Lord will tell you everything. I have sent him to you for this very purpose that
you may know how we are and that he may encourage your hearts. Peace be to the
brothers in love with faith from God the Father and the Lord Jesus Christ.
Grace be with all who love our Lord Jesus Christ with love incorruptible.
This is the word of the word. Thanks be to God.
Let's pray together, shall we?
Father, we come to you through Jesus praying that you would give us the
spirit of wisdom and of revelation in the knowledge of you. Lord, I pray that
you would enlighten the eyes of our hearts that we may know the hope
to which we have been called. We would know the riches of your glorious
inheritance in the saints and that we would know the immeasurable greatness
of your power toward us who believe according to the working of your great
might that you worked in Christ when you raised him from the dead and seated
him at the right hand in the heavenly places. His name we pray. Amen.
When you worship God, if you look at, there's a little blurb on the back
of it, which says our vision and it just gives you a one Senate summary of
what we are about as a church and what we are aiming to do together.
It says, Trinity exists to be a worshiping community on mission for
the glory of God from North Jefferson to the ends of the earth.
And each one of these main ideas that are packed into that single
Senate are here for us in the book of Ephesians. We didn't base it on
the book of Ephesians, but you see the that same flow here in the book.
You see it beginning with worship. It begins with blessing God for all
that he has done for us in Christ. And it moves on to community.
This new humanity that God is creating in Christ called the church.
We see, we saw there what it means to live together and to grow
together as the people of God, as the body of Christ.
But having worshiped God and seeing the community he is calling us to be,
we also see finally that we are on mission together.
Last week we saw that we are in a spiritual battle with spiritual enemies,
but it's not the sort of battle where we're kind of hunkered down,
waiting till Jesus comes. It is, it's a battle where we are
standing firm against the attacks of the enemy.
And last week we saw what that is, but we're standing firm, but we're
we're standing firm that we might continue to move forward for the sake
of the gospel. OK, we want the gospel to continue to shape our lives together.
And we want to see it spread to those who have never heard the message before.
So this morning, as we look at the close of this book, we're going to look
at two key ways the gospel advances, right?
So we're standing firm that we might move forward for the sake of the gospel.
And we see two particular ways that the gospel advances.
So we're going to look at prayer and then we're going to look at mission
partnership, so prayer and mission partnership.
So prayer, first of all, there in verse 18 of Ephesians six.
You know, Paul has told us that we're to be strong in the Lord
and the strength of his might, that we're to put on the whole
armor of God than in verse 18.
He says praying at all times in the spirit with all prayer and supplication.
To that end, keep alert with all perseverance, making supplication for all the saints.
All right, so last week we saw that in Christ, God has provided us with
the armor that we need, so to speak, that we might stand against
the schemes of the devil.
And prayer is mentioned at the very end of that list of the different
pieces of armor, but he's not moving on to a new subject.
Like he's looked at the armor.
Now we're going to look at prayer together.
No, he's continuing with the same thought.
And Paul doesn't give a specific illustration to go with this
piece of armor of prayer.
But John Piper did in his book, Let the Nations Be Glad.
And I'll just share with you the illustration that he used in that book.
He talked about prayer as almost being like a walkie talkie.
And it fits in well with this kind of wartime context of prayer here in the book.
He said this, he said, we cannot know what prayer is until we know that life is war.
Our weakness in prayer is owing largely to our neglect of this truth.
Prayer is primarily a wartime walkie talkie for the mission of the church as
it advances against the powers of darkness and unbelief.
It's not surprising.
He goes on to say that prayer malfunctions when we try to make it a domestic
intercom to call upstairs for more comforts in the den.
God has given us prayer as a wartime walkie talkie so that we can call
headquarters for everything we need as the kingdom of Christ advances
in the world.
Right.
So that's the context of our of our prayers.
So in prayer, we are laying hold of what God has provided for us in
Christ so that we might stand firm no matter what we face and that we might
move forward for the sake of the gospel.
So that's the context of our prayers.
But let's see the instructions that are given on prayer and really the
instructions on prayer deal with a couple of different big categories.
One is God's presence with us in prayer.
And then the other one is our practices in prayer.
So first of all, God's presence.
So when we pray, um, generally speaking, we're praying to the father.
Okay.
So there's, there's, it's, there's a Trinitarian thing happening when we're
praying, we're praying to the father, through the son and by the spirit.
Okay.
So God is the one who's leading us in prayer through the son to the father.
So Paul tells us, where do we see that here?
Paul tells us that we are to pray in the spirit at all times in verse 18.
So what does it mean then to pray in the spirit?
Well, some people immediately think of like having an ecstatic experience in prayer,
when it comes to praying in the spirit.
But here we see that it's written in reference to all different kinds of prayer.
So prayer in the spirit is essentially this, it is prayer that is being guided
and enabled by the spirit of God.
So as we're praying, when we're praying in the spirit, we're remembering,
first of all, that God is already present with us as we pray.
Now, many people like conceptualize of prayer as like an attempt by people to
reach out and to lay hold of a God who is distant from us.
And it can feel like, you know, you're, you're reading off a wish list or
thinking your own thoughts, like wondering if they're going any higher than
the ceiling, because you conceptualize of prayer as trying to get to where
God is.
But here we see that God is not distant.
He's the God who delights to dwell among his people.
We have seen that already in the book that we were the temple of God.
So God delights to dwell with us.
He is not distant.
He is not reluctant, but he is the God who is already near and ready to
help us by the person of his Holy Spirit.
So as we come to pray, we're remembering God is already present.
Here he's not reluctant.
He's willing and he's welcoming us in prayer.
But also we're remembering the work of the spirit.
So God is present, but he's also at work.
So in Ephesians, we've seen that God's spirit we saw in chapter one,
enlightens our eyes that we might come to know God.
So we come to know God by the work of the spirit.
He opens our eyes to see and to believe who God is.
But we also saw that he empowers us that we might live for him.
And both of those things apply to praying in the spirit as well.
So it is by the spirit that we are assured that we are coming to a heavenly
father who has who loves us, who's adopted us into his family
and who welcomes us into his presence in prayer.
So the spirit assures us that because of the work of Christ,
we are children of God.
So where do we see that?
We see that in Romans chapter eight and verses 15 and 16.
It says this says, you have received the spirit of adoption as sons
by whom we cry, that is by whom we pray, Abba, father.
And he goes on to say, the spirit himself bears witness with our spirit
that we are children of God.
Right. So the spirit opens our eyes so that we might know God as our father.
But then in Romans eight and verse 26, we see that the spirit helps us
when we struggle to find words to pray.
It says, likewise, the spirit helps us in our weakness, for we do not know
what to pray as we ought, but the spirit himself intercedes for us
with groanings too deep for words.
Right. So the spirit can give us words and prayer to pray.
It helps us in all kinds of prayer.
But even when we don't know what to pray and all we're doing is
groaning in a Godward direction, the spirit is able to take those groanings
and bring it to the father in prayer.
So praying in the spirit is remember that the God of grace is there with you
and he's helping you by his spirit in prayer.
What does that look like in practice?
So he talks about different practices in prayer here.
Now, interestingly, when you look at it, Paul doesn't give a lot of
a lot of details in prayer here, but he at the same time,
he still covers like all the bases in what he says.
So he talks about prayer in a way that is comprehensive.
He uses the word all like four times in this in this short passage.
So the whole church is to be characterized by, we might say,
an abundance of prayer, all the kinds of prayer that Paul is speaking
about here. And when Paul speaks about all these kinds of prayer,
we also see that we have all kinds of room to grow.
I'm sure myself included.
So when we pray, let's look at these four alls, we're to pray.
On all occasions, he says, at all times.
So if God is always present with us and his strength is always available,
it therefore follows that we should be praying at all times.
We should be living consciously in his presence.
So it's good to have those all times certainly include set times of prayer
like we read this in the book of Psalms, they're being set times of prayer
or in the practices of Daniel or in the ministry of Jesus.
Like it's good for us to have set times of prayer individually and together as the church.
But this is also an invitation to live in continual communion with God.
So there's those kind of anchored times.
But even as we go about our day, we're to live.
A life of prayer.
So this is something we can all grow in individually.
I'm sure. Like as we go throughout our days, knowing what it is,
to commune with God in everything that we're doing at work, at home,
whatever we're going through.
But it's also something we can grow in as a as a church.
I mean, wouldn't it be great to have the kind of the culture of prayer in the church?
Even in these early days, where conversations become
they more and more naturally ease into prayer for one another.
What if we made it a practice where we aren't the sorts of people who just say
the kind of token phrase of I will pray for you, but we actually pray.
And maybe even better, we pause, we stop and we we pray right then and there
to actually be a prayerful people as the church.
So often we're all too easily timid or forgetful or distracted in prayer.
So we see the word to pray with what else does he say with all perseverance
to that end, keep alert with all perseverance in prayer.
So in Acts chapter two, we see that the early church devoted themselves to prayer.
They continue on.
And but at the same time, I'm encouraged that the Bible doesn't just give us
the kind of the highlight stories where things went well, where that people
really persevering in prayer, but it also gives us the kind of the stories
that we might be tempted to kind of tuck away somewhere.
Because what Paul says here about prayer, about staying alert,
harkens back to the ministry of Jesus.
So Matthew 26, for example, we read about him taking
three of his disciples to the Garden of Gethsemane with him while he is there
to pray just before he goes to the cross.
And what does he say to them there?
He says, watch and pray that you may not enter into temptation.
The spirit indeed is willing, but the flesh is weak.
And so when he comes back to his disciples, what does he find them doing?
They're fast asleep.
They're to be alert in prayer.
So I find that encouraging, like if the disciples did it, you know,
the apostles knew the struggles that I face in prayer,
then the spirit knows my weaknesses and is able to help me in prayer as well.
But let's move on. What are we to pray?
OK, so praying all the time, persevering in it with all kinds of prayers.
So he talks about prayers with all prayers and supplications.
Another word for that is requests.
So depending on your church background, when you think about praying,
a lot of different styles of praying might come to mind.
And you might wonder, like, which one is right?
Which one do I go with?
The encouraging thing is in scripture, you actually find a range
of different modes of prayer.
So you find people praying alone, but you also find people praying with others.
You find people praying silently, but you also find people praying out loud
and sometimes really loud.
You find people praying at length.
And sometimes you find people praying very brief prayers.
We find kind of pre-scripted written prayers.
I mean, look at the book of Psalms where we're actually praying
the words of scripture together, but then you also find extemporaneous prayer
where it wasn't kind of pre-written, where you are praying in a more spontaneous way.
So it's all there.
But the important thing is that we're praying.
And a range of different subjects are covered in prayer in scripture.
Acts is a helpful acronym.
I'm not talking about the book, but just the ACTS.
And there's more types of prayer in scripture than this, but it's a helpful
one to remember as you're coming to pray.
You see, you find prayers of adoration where we are worshiping God,
where we're beholding his face in prayer, praising him.
But then you have prayers of confession where we are repenting of our sins.
You have prayers of thanksgiving where we're remembering all that God has done
for us in Christ and we're giving him thanks for all that he has done.
You have to ask prayers of supplication where we're bringing our requests to God,
but we're not just praying for ourselves, but also praying for others.
And that last part is what Paul really leans into here.
He gives more attention to this.
He says, the word to be praying for the end of verse 18, all the saints.
Pray for all of them.
Back at Christmas time, we got to visit my in-laws in England,
and we got to spend time with my father-in-law there.
And several months back, they moved house to a different city
in a different part of England, and they had been living in this other place
for decades, for a long, long time, and really where he was born.
And now they moved this new place.
And I asked him just in conversation, I said, you know, it's been
it's been a long time now.
Like, are there are there still people that you're keeping in contact with?
Like, who are the folks that you still check in with?
And he paused for a second.
He was almost embarrassed by his answer.
And he said, well, I still pray for all of them as I work through the list
every week.
He said, and as I pray for them, I get in contact with a number
of different ones to see what specific things I can be praying for them.
And man, I was really challenged by that.
He was, well, yes, I keep in contact with them, but I'm praying
for every one of them by name, even though I'm in a different place.
And that's the kind of prayer that Paul is encouraging here,
not just amongst like church leaders, but he's, he's encouraging
all of us to be prayerful for all the saints.
Those that we are around here, those that we are around in other places
are those that we are not even seeing at the moment.
This abundance of prayers, praying for all kinds of people all the time.
So wonder how that's been seen maybe in our lives even this week.
But having instructed them to pray for all the saints, he unashamedly
in verse 19, then asked them to pray for him.
So he says, pray also for me.
And that brings us to this second way, the gospel advances.
It advances not only through our prayers, but also through mission
partnerships, you might say.
So praying for all the saints includes praying for gospel workers
and gospel work in other places.
Child psychologists tell us that babies have to get up to a certain age
before they develop what is called object permanence.
And if you're familiar with object permanence, it's when it's the idea
that when you move an object out of the direct line of sight of a baby
and maybe like cover it over or something, it's as though it doesn't
exist anymore, it's as though it's completely disappeared.
It's right there.
But because it's out of the direct line of sight, it's like it's
not even there anymore.
Maybe that's why peekaboo is such an exciting game or something
like you've completely disappeared.
Where did you go?
And now you're back again.
But then as they mature, they develop the ability to know that
even though I can't see it, that doesn't mean it's not there anymore.
So why do I mention that?
Well, part of our maturing in Christ is growing in our awareness
of and our concern for people and gospel work happening in other
places that are outside of our direct line of sight.
Right?
So as we're growing together in Christ, yes, we're concerned for
what we can see, but also concerned for the Lord's work in other places
as we mature in Him.
But what can happen so often in mission work is out of sight, out
of mind can kick in.
It's like we don't see it.
Therefore, we don't talk about it.
We don't pray for it.
But although it's happening in another place, we can still
partner with the work to quote the missionary William Kerry.
We can hold the rope while others go down into the pit.
There's a there's a partnership when it comes to the proclamation of the gospel.
So what Paul asks the church to do for him can still be done today.
And keep in mind as we read what he's about to say that he's not
writing to the missions committee of the church at Ephesus.
He is writing to the whole church.
Right?
So often mission can be thought of like, well, that's that's a
kind of a niche thing that if you happen to be interested in that type of
ministry, you get involved in it, you join the missions committee or whatever.
But he's writing here to the entire church saying that they should be all
interested in what he is about to say and partner with him in this work.
So how can we partner with gospel work in other places?
I just three quick things.
One is take an interest.
We should be interested in what is happening in other places because
God's word tells us about what he is doing around the world.
So it's a matter of us listening to what God has said to us, what he's given to us.
So in verse 19, Paul writes again about the mystery of the gospel.
And to go back to chapter three and verse six, we were told there that
the mystery of the gospel that is now revealed is that it was God's
intention from the beginning to create one global church that is made up
of Jews and Gentiles alike.
And we can see this mystery all the way throughout scripture, but here it's
revealed that it's God's intention through the death of Christ to redeem
a people for his name from all nations and incorporate them into this one
body called the church.
So that's what Paul is talking about here when he talks about the mystery
of the gospel.
He wants the church to understand what mission is all about.
Mission is about seeing that brought to fruition, especially through
the preaching of the gospel.
Like Christ purchased this people for his name from all nations.
And as we proclaim his gospel to all the world, it's being brought into
fruition, they're being brought in.
And Paul is focusing on here on the proclamation of the gospel.
That's what he is there to do.
Now this should be, this should interest us when it comes to global
missions, first of all, because we're invited to be part of that global
family.
No matter who we are, what we've done, what our background is, we're
invited to come to know God.
But also we're called to participate in what God is doing around the world.
God is growing his church locally and globally through the proclamation
of the gospel, and he's inviting us to participate in that great work.
Okay, so we should take an interest in that, but also we should take
an interest in specific people who are taking the gospel to specific
places.
So this isn't just like, he's not saying like pray that God would bless
all the missionaries around the world or like pray for mission in a general way.
But rather he's encouraging us to build specific relationships with
specific people.
So Paul wants the church to know about what he is up to.
Not only that, he sends a man called Ticacus who is going to share more.
Now Ticacus is one of those workers who deserves more attention
than we tend to give him.
He pops up in a few places.
In Acts chapter 20 he's mentioned as one of the people from one of the churches
that had been planted.
No doubt he was from Asia, who was with Paul as he was traveling.
He also served as like a pastor temporarily in places.
But here we see he's almost like working as a male man.
Right?
So information doesn't travel as quickly in that day.
And so he's actually taking this letter to the Ephesians to them
and he's available to encourage them to to speak to them.
No doubt about some of the contents of the letter, but also to share about
how Paul is doing and what he is doing as well.
He's getting into the specifics here.
But in Ticacus though, here's what I want us to say.
We have this relational connection to what is happening elsewhere.
He's kind of serving as a living link between the local church and its global mission.
And that can still happen today as people come to us to share about the gospel work
that they are involved in in other places that they've been to see.
And it's a real privilege to to have Chris with us who's going to share here
in a minute about what he is involved in.
So we should be taking an interest in and people are involved in that kind of work
and what they are doing.
But the invitation is not only to take an interest, but to get involved.
Now, how do we get involved?
Well, some will go and others will send and support, but all of us are called to be
involved in it in one way or another.
So I'm praying that the Lord would call some of us to go from here to other
other places, other parts of the world to serve in a gospel work somewhere else.
Jesus told us to pray to the Lord of the harvest to send forth laborers into
his harvest.
And the fact is if the gospel is going to go to all the world, people will have to
leave the comforts of home to cross boundaries and go to new places and peoples.
So that there are those who go, but there are also those who send and support
gospel work in other places.
So in order for people to go, churches need to be ready to stand behind them,
to send them, to support them as they go.
And you might have mission partners that you are supporting personally, and that's
wonderful, but let's also pray together that the Lord would direct us even in
these early months as a church to mission partners that we can partner
with collectively to support in the work that they are doing.
And that can take all kinds of forms that can look like giving financially
towards the work.
It can look like encouraging them and like what you say or writing to them
or visiting, but there's a particular emphasis here and that is supporting
through prayer.
And so as we pray, what are we praying for?
We are praying.
I mean, take the words of Ticacus here.
He says, I'm going to take his ticket is going to share about how Paul is
doing and also what he is doing.
So as we're praying, we're praying for, we might say, gospel workers
and gospel work.
We're praying for them and what they are doing.
So we're praying for them personally.
We're really caring for our mission partners.
We're caring for how they're doing mentally, physically, emotionally,
spiritually, checking in with them to see how they're doing.
We genuinely care for them, but we're also praying for the work that they are
doing to and Paul is really emphasizing in what he writes here,
the work that he is doing.
He's in prison.
And if you were in prison, I don't know what you'd be asking for prayer
for. I'd be praying for like, please pray for my release.
But instead of praying for his release, he's praying that he would
represent Christ well where he is.
He thinks of himself as an ambassador in change, right?
So an ambassador is representing another kingdom.
So he's there representing Christ's kingdom and he's aiming to proclaim
Christ to those he's been brought in contact with even during his imprisonment.
This is what he's asking the church to pray for.
Pray that words would be given to me in the opening of my mouth
to boldly proclaim the mystery of the gospel for which I am an ambassador
in chains, that I may declare it boldly as I ought to speak.
So as we pray for mission partners, whatever work they are involved in,
let's pray that they would represent Christ well and that specifically
that they would know the spirit's help when it comes to having courage
and clarity in the proclamation of the gospel.
We want to see them care for people well in all kinds of ways,
but more than anything, we want to see Christ made known through them,
through their works and through their words.
Paul writes here in a way that makes makes a clear, direct connection
between our prayers and the global advance of the gospel.
I remember being challenged years ago, reading the biography of James Fraser.
He was a missionary in the kind of early 20th century.
He was serving amongst the Lisu people in Western China.
And they were hard people to work amongst.
And but he really believed in the power of prayer.
And he used to gather groups together back in England or write to them
and encourage them to gather together to pray.
And it wasn't just a kind of token thing.
That's not how we viewed it. Here's what he wrote.
He said, I am not asking you.
This is in writing to one of those prayer groups.
He says, I'm not writing to ask you to give help in prayer as a sort of
sideline, but I'm trying to roll the main responsibility
of this prayer warfare on to you.
I want you to take the burden of these people on your shoulders.
I want you to wrestle with God for them.
You could then go on later to read about the the impact of the
gospel amongst this specific people group.
No doubt there was a direct connection with the prayers of God's people.
Now, I don't I don't presume to know how God is going to use your prayers,
but I do believe that God will use them.
As part of his global purpose to advance the gospel for the glory of his name.
So we should take an interest in our mission partners.
We should get involved in what they're doing, especially through prayer.
We should also imitate their example.
What do I say that?
Say that because it's a bit hypocritical to pray something for somebody
else that you would be unwilling to do yourself.
You know, as though like, yep, we want them to make Christ known somewhere else.
But don't pray that for us here.
They might be carrying out a different role in a different context,
but the mission is the same wherever you are.
Is there anything the church could learn from Paul's example here?
Well, certainly about living as Christ's ambassadors right where we are.
Living as people who are part of his kingdom.
His kingdom.
How about praying for boldness to speak of Christ to others and clarity
in doing that here in our context?
How about being willing to suffer for his name?
I mean, it's almost ridiculous to even say that thinking about like Paul in prison.
A couple of weeks ago, there were 70 believers in Congo who were beheaded
for their faith and were found in a church.
And we could talk about immense suffering that's going around the world today.
The people are by the grace of God standing firm.
So we should be willing to suffer, I don't know, mockery or the role of people's eyes
or whatever for the sake of his name.
He is worth it.
And engaging well with our mission partners and being and being more familiar
with what is happening in other places can really stir our hearts
to be on mission right where we are here.
But the fact that we're being asked to pray for all of these things reminds us
of where our strength comes from.
It comes from the Lord.
He will enable us to be faithful as partners in the gospel.
So this brings us to the final words of benediction in the letter.
Paul speaks here, reminding us once again that our God is a God of peace
and love and grace and that has been shown to us in Jesus.
So we can know peace with God.
We can know his love and his grace, not because of the amount of hours
we've logged in prayer or how faithful we've been in proclaiming the gospel,
you know, how many people we've shared it with or whatever.
We can know all of those things through Jesus by the help of the Spirit.
And it's interesting as we close out this letter, he speaks about.
This is his grace be with all of you who love our Lord Jesus Christ
with love incorruptible.
He's already spoken about grace and peace and love.
But this is the first time he speaks about our love for God.
So everything that we've learned together in Ephesians isn't just there
so we might we might learn things about God or about the church
or or do things for him.
It's most fundamentally that we might know God himself
and that we might love God with all of our hearts.
So as we know him, his grace, his peace and his love, the right response
is to is to love him to receive his love for us and to enter into this
loving relationship that will last forever.
Let's pray together, shall we?
Well, we look forward to the day when the battles that we face
in this life will be over and we will be with you forever more.
But I pray that even now on this day that we would stand firm, rest assured
that we are loved by you in Christ and that you have provided all that
we need that we might stand for him.
It's Lord, I pray that by the help of your spirit that we would come
to you, that we would come to know you as the God who has welcomed us in him.
And Lord, I pray that you would help us to be people as we just thought
about, we would be people of prayer and who have a living relationship with you
and people who are faithful in partnering together for the sake of the
gospel, both locally and globally.
We ask all this in Jesus' name.
Amen.